so as of today i'm in my second year of
my phds so this time i wanted to talk a
little bit into the amazing topic of our
gut and how our gut affects our brain to
this god's brain axis as they now call
it and probably if i didn't do my
research in computational neuroscience i
wouldn't have done it about the gut
because they nowadays call our gut our
second brain because that's how much
influence the gut has on our general
well-being and our mood and i kind of
want to talk about how we can optimize
our diet to improve our gut health and
through improving our gut health also
improving our brain function so i've
gone through all the papers and linked
all the resources down below so if you
have anything that you think like ah
that's maybe not entirely right or not
entirely what i'm looking for i do
encourage you highly to also look at
some papers yourself and find some of
the resources that you need for the
questions you have
so grab yourself a coffee
and let's have coffee time
[Music]
so in neuroscience we kind of had to
rediscover that our brain actually does
not exist in a vacuum but it actually
exists in our body so the health of our
body directly influences how our brain
functions and as our brain is kind of
the view of how we perceive the world
our body then also influences things
like our mood and our perception of the
world and one of the biggest influers
that determines our bodily health and
therefore our brain health is the gut so
the gut is one part of the body that has
a direct link to the brain through the
vagus nerve and we can kind of see the
vagus nerve as the highway in our body
where the fastest traveling signals go
through and this is then the link
between our two brains so on the one
hand the brain in your head and on the
other hand the brain in your gusto
intestinal tract and the main function
scientists thought primarily of this
direct link was to tell the brain
exactly when we are full or when we are
hungry and evolutionarily of course this
is the most important
thing for us to find food and survive so
another way that the guts in the brain
are actually linked is through
neurotransmitters and neurotransmitters
are the body's chemical messengers so
for example serotonin is one of these
messengers that helps stabilize our mood
regulates our happiness and gives
feelings of general
well-being
and one of the interesting things is
that serotonin isn't primarily produced
in the brain but actually is also
produced in our guts which is then quite
interesting so if you eat ice cream and
you get this feeling of intense
happiness this intense happiness feeling
probably doesn't directly originate from
your brain but actually originates
directly from your stomach
but nowadays scientists are also
figuring out that not only feelings of
extreme happiness can originate from
your gut but also
more
negative feelings such as anxiousness or
depression so the saying a gut feeling
is actually less subjective than one
might think so let's get into a little
bit of the research
so there are two type of main research
done in this area of gut health and its
correlation to the brain and one is done
on animals primarily rats which actually
have very similar brains to humans and
the other research is done directly on
human participants
but the negative point of
research with people like you and me is
that we cannot just
influence all the factors so i want you
to keep this in the back of your mind
whilst i present the research
so let's first start with the research
on animals
so our really interesting research
showed that if you had certain mice that
were more anxious as opposed to more
happy mice that if you transferred their
gut microbes the anxious mice actually
became more happy or less anxious
and
non-anxious mice or the normal mice and
she became more anxious and this is
really interesting because this shows
that there is a direct causal link
between the bacteria that live in our
gut and the feelings that animals have
and we are also animals so probably for
us this is also true so if you're
feeling extremely upset or anxious it's
maybe not only coming from your brain
but maybe also from what you just ate or
if you have an upset stomach so that's
something to think about and it has also
been shown that signals from our guts
directly activate the hippocampus and
the hippocampus is this center mainly
known for learning and memory and
scientists used to think that this was
then
activated for animals as well as humans
to remember where they found the food
and that's why probably when you think
back on this loving date you had that
you can remember the spaghetti you ate
much more clearly than the conversation
you actually had and i was also shown by
a study on mice that when they had a
beef and rich diet versus a normal diet
that their learning and memory was
actually improved a little bit and
that's not to say that you now have to
go eat a lot of beef but it is to say
that if you change the gut microbe
learning and memory is directly affected
and another extremely interesting
finding in animals was that if they
changed or transferred certain gut
microbes from one mice to another that
actually their behavior could change so
their personality could actually change
depending on what kind of bacteria they
had in their gut
so this is kind of to say that if you
have a really grumpy neighbor maybe it's
not that he has a bad personality maybe
his gut is just upset so next time he
screams at you about some trash you
didn't throw away properly just tell him
to eat a yogurt and perhaps your
relationship problems will be solved so
now let's go away from the animals let's
go into some human research
so one of the interesting findings in
human research was that people who have
feelings of depression anxiety and
correlations of these that they also
haven't
disturbed a gut microbe and that's and
it is kind of hard to pinpoint exactly
if the feelings of depression or anxiety
cause the stomach to be upset or if the
upset stomach causes feelings of
depression or anxiety and furthermore it
has also been shown that the gut's
microbiota
and our diet actually also
influences the course of certain
psychiatric disorders
so there are now some doctors that
propose a more holistic view of the
treatment of these psychiatric disorders
and this is to say that they don't only
propose medicine as a cure but medicine
together with some psychological
interviews as well as an exercise regime
and probably re-learning how to have a
healthy lifestyle which then also
includes diet and another study has
actually shown that the transfer of
lean individuals got microbiota to
more heavier individuals actually
increase the insulin sensitivity of
these heavier individuals and insulin
sensitivity is one of the pre-diabetic
conditions so this is to say that
actually some of the cures of obesity
could perhaps be found in having a more
healthy god's microbiome and this could
then
for example be introduced by a healthier
diet or by directly transferring these
guts microbiota between individuals
which i think is super interesting
because this really shows
that the disbalance of wanting to eat a
lot more for people with a heavier
weight doesn't only come from the mind
but actually it's also their body
telling them dispersing signals this is
then one of the first indication that
good bacteria can help with maintaining
unhealthy weight and bad bacteria can
actually increase some of the weight
gain so let's get into some tips and
tricks to actually solve some of the
problems that you may have with your
guts
so i do want to say i'm not a dietitian
so if you're thinking about introducing
any of the things i say into your diet
and you have some doubts if it's healthy
for you do consult a professional or
your doctor because this is always a
good idea to get a second view on the
decisions you make about your body but
it's kind of interesting that in the
modern westernized world we have an
abundance of food but actually most of
these food is nutrition poor so that is
to say that a lot of them lack
some certain vitamins that are super
important for our gut health and also
our brain health therefore and in an
austrian study one of the few vitamins
that was found to be lacking in a
majority of the population was vitamin b
folate magnesium and fiber and
especially fiber we now know is super
important for your gut health and fiber
can be found in a large bar of foods but
especially in fruits
and vegetables so as we all know this is
already super healthy for your health
but also for your guts then so i would
just recommend to eat an abundance of
fruit and veggies
and include them as much as possible in
your daily
eating regime so there has also been
this trend of including probiotics and
prebiotics in our diet
but
some of the findings that have been
found was for example that women who
were introduced to a fermented milk
product with probiotics
that their brain activity to certain
areas was modulated
by this
so probiotics can for example be found
in the form of pills in certain health
stores but the way i would introduce
these kind of
healthy
benefits of probiotics is true natural
foods so such as kefir kimchi sauerkraut
which is kind of popular here and of
course is super popular right now
kombucha which i think is super
delicious and for general brain health
there has been some science that
suggested that the mediterranean diet
is the most superior of all diets for
our
mental cognitive abilities so the
mediterranean diet consists of a few
things so it includes vegetables fruit
and nuts
legumes fish
unsaturated fatty acids such as found in
avocado
so but i would recommend instead of
running to the nearest supermarket and
buying all the italian
produce i would just look around in your
area to see what kind of things are
readily available that are for example
fruit and veggies or include some
natural
healthy fats so if you live in an area
that has an abundance of avocados of
course choose that but for example in
the netherlands that's not super readily
found so yeah i would just look in your
environment what's there go to your
local farmer migrants because i do think
our bodies are naturally kind of adapted
to the environment we live in so just
eating what is locally produced will
probably be most beneficial for your
body's physiological needs and your
mind's psychological needs so there's
also been some increased interest in
these adaptogenic herbs so adaptogenics
are these non-toxic herbs that you can
see here and they're mostly found in for
example health stores or in traditional
medicine they're used a lot and also
nowadays in more like lattes and teas
and there are some studies that show
that they are beneficial for example in
improving your gut health or reducing
stress
but to be very honest i don't find these
studies super convincing i do think the
benefits of these herbs are very minimal
but if you have some extra money or
interest or time to spare i would look
into some of the
benefits
so summing up i would recommend to eat
mainly like the mediterranean diet but
adapt it to your local produce
eat as much fruit and veg as possible
try to introduce some fermented foods
like kimchi or kombucha and if you're
super interested also sprinkle some
herbs on top stick as these can really
optimize
your guts as well as your brain
and then probably you're ready to live
that healthy god-brain life
so thank you for joining me on this
coffee time and until the next time
[Music]
you